well the heads of the CIA and Israeli
intelligence agency have arrived in
delha for talks with katari officials
and they're also joined by the chief of
the Egyptian spy agency now Qatar has
been the main mediator in negotiations
with Hamas for the release of Israeli
captives and Palestinian prisoners let's
speak to our White House correspondent
kimly Hala what more are you learning
about this
trip well the CIA doesn't generally talk
about the meetings that are taking place
it's usually for a spy agency not
surprisingly quite closed uh Li when it
comes to those details but what we do
know is that the desire of the United
States and the Biden Administration is
for this meeting to result in building
on the temporary truce agreement or
ceasefire agreement that's already in
place the goal of the United States is
to try and see more captives released
and also more humanitarian Aid being
brought into Gaza and so what we know in
addition to that is that the National
Security Council has also announced that
there will be three military flights
that will be heading to the region
Landing in Northern Egypt we understand
and that the aid that continues to flow
in will be dispensed through the United
Nations now all of this is a result of a
lot of domestic as well as International
pressure on the Biden Administration
given the fact that it has been backing
Israel in its war on Gaza and the
enormous number of Palestinian
casualties that is not sitting well with
many here in the United States and so as
a result this meeting is also going to
be looking at what governance looks like
in Gaza following the what the Israelis
say is their ultimate goal and that is
to defeat the the leadership of Hamas
and really to loosen its grip on Gaza
right and Kimberly we understand that
the White House has been discussing uh
Palestinian civilian displacement what
more can you tell us about
that yeah that's right uh well in terms
of the displacement the big concern is
is that there is going to be Mass
casualties as a result of people moving
from the north to the South and so what
the administration is working with
Israel on is making sure that there is
going to be Precision in the military
campaigns that Israel says it is
planning to resume once the the
agreement that is currently in place
finally ends uh and as we've noted there
is this desire to extend it but that is
not uh any sort of definite for firm
plan at this moment so the concern is of
all of this is that uh there's going to
be further mass casualty and that's
something that the United States is
under enormous pressure to stop and is
now using its leverage with Israel to
try and do so and so far what we're
hearing is that the Israelis are
receptive even as they vow to continue
their military campaign okay thank you
Kimberly Hut reporting from the White
House